I'm just going to run you through a
handful of the proofs and how I'm going
to use triangles and each other to proof
these okay because some of them are
really quite profound but they they make
quite easy statement okay so for example
let's look it up a seven so this is
angle at the centre there's the set up
right um is twice the angles that's why
over to the angular circumference
standing on the same arc so this idea of
an angle standing on an arc is literally
thinking about the parts of the angle
the two intervals before the angle is
kind of like the legs right so it's
standing here okay so that's what you
should visualize by the way just as a
tip you're going to go through a whole
bunch of these proofs and you will meet
them in exams as well if you stare right
you're like it's not clicking I've
already told you the very very first tip
was which all the thing okay like I said
as you draw here's the reason why it
works in case you want it's not just
black magic right as you draw it forces
your brain to understand the
relationships between the different
points of the different lines and the
different arcs better than if you just
look at the thing just look at the thing
okay in exactly the same way that in a
conversation they tell you okay if you
want to get to do someone better
or like remember their name or something
like that what you do is you say back to
them in different words the thing
they're saying to you rather than just
sort of naughty naughty naughty and then
five minutes later you're like man what
we were talking about okay you force
yourself to articulate you force
yourself to construct okay the other tip
is and this is why it's it's clearly
this one if after you draw it
it's still not clicky turn the thing
upside down turn the thing upside down
you'd be surprised just like drawing and
how effective that kind of thing is and
it's useful here because you can't
necessarily see oh it's standing right
because the language does not is not as
clear right but if you turn around it's
pretty obvious now how would you go
about proving this it's worth mentioning
that for this particular property you
can actually draw different diagrams to
represent this for example here another
way
at there you go so this is the same
situation right I've got an angle at the
center which is double the angle at the
circumference standing on the same ah
okay so the proof I'm about to give you
doesn't quite exactly work for this even
though works first because the
configuration is slightly different okay
but it's not that hard
how would we construct this thing how
would we prove that this angles are the
way they are yeah okay good so because
again we said triangles because it's
such a special shape go all these
special properties you've got radii
flying everywhere
right everywhere so therefore as Justin
I've got that so where do I go from
there yeah very good
so as soon as I've got if I define that
just let that be any thing you like what
we've called Athena that makes it
theater over there because isosceles and
then right there with no further
construction the exterior angle of a
triangle is equal to the sum of the
opposite interior to deal really easy
right where you come down to here you're
going to take advantage of another thing
because you've got the radio everywhere
you know isosceles triangles everywhere
okay if I wanted to prove that this
angle of the setup which I just indicate
with the dot sorry yeah angle in a
semicircle I listen to kept the diamond
up with a dot there how would I do it
one line
okay form the isosceles triangles right
and then what you've got here is I call
this alpha that's alpha right isosceles
you happy with that if I call this beta
I've got a bead over there right because
again isosceles triangles I'm done
do you see it yet what's the angle sum
of a triangle 180 degrees so I've got to
our 4 plus 2 beta is 180 therefore alpha
plus beta is 90 right just like that I
think that's really beautiful
right number nine flows straight out of
either of these two right probably
probably seven is the easiest right I've
got a whole bunch of angles all in the
circumference and apparently they're all
equal
how did you go about showing you now
Congress is going to be a bit tricky
Congress will be tricky because with
these it's not obvious but if I put one
over here it's still true but you better
believe that's not concrete right it's
not even close to convert in fact none
of my original ones will convert either
so what would you do
where you going to get to the end the
relationship
an angle at the top yeah bingo all right
so here we go
I've already proved this and that was
easy right so these are all standing on
the same arc right they're all on the
circumference so if I make one say he
are right in the middle if you just
start from this guy and you don't know
these two right well this angle is at
the circumference standing on this are
down here so this one must be double
that it's twice the angle the sum of its
goods at the center right
what's your this this one over here is
also standing on the same arm right so
it must be another way the converse
obviously you could say instead of
saying it's twice the angle you can say
the one of the scum Fritz's half the
angle to set up and then you do it again
right so there's like a missing piece
there just like this was a missing piece
yeah